hello my name is richard mitchmore
and i'm the director of the genome
center at uc davis
and what i'm going to do today is to
describe
uh how we've ramped up high throughput
testing for covid
and then how that led to an opportunity
for
high throughput characterization of
variance
and really going forward what type of um
surveillance strategy should we be using
for monitoring for variants of concern
so just a little bit of background you
know davis is
uh at the head of the san joaquin valley
very fertile area in california about
northwest
of sacramento in san francisco
and what we're doing here is we're
serving
uh both the campus and the city of davis
for covid testing we're about thirty
000 students and
1500 faculty and the college town is
about
35 000 individuals so that's that's our
target population
when kovid started to uh ramp up the
pandemic
there was a lot of discussion about the
concept of high throughput testing
and much of the testing was being done
on infection
symptomatic individuals and it was
taking
five seven days to get the results back
this really is not ideal
for community-grade surveillance testing
in that many of the
individuals are asymptomatic and this
window based on on data from michael
mienes at harvard
you can see that the infectious period
is only about five to six days
and if you delay if you sample at the
top of that peak
you delay for a week and then you
contact trace back two days
it's really not uh not valuable
so what we needed was rapid inexpensive
high throughput workflows
and the sensitivity was somewhat
secondary to frequency and turnaround
time
if you want a really very sensitive
uh test and you have slow return of
results it's really a waste of time and
resources
so what we did was
i come from an ag biotech background i
knew
that there was technology out there from
the ag biotech sector
would allow very high throughput testing
in the biotech sector the big ad
companies they can generate
millions of data points a day orders of
magnitude
higher than what was being considered by
the
medical testing community and the
machine you see in the middle
is deployed and the advice sectors will
have multiple of these
and i'd say they can generate millions
of data points a day but the end point
we chose to go with the intellicube it's
the platform you see on the left
which is actually a qpcr machine that
can do massively parallel
qpcr reactions and the way that they do
that if you look on the right
is that an array tape which is
essentially
an array of 768
wells uh plates on a tape
that you can mount their reactions on
and then analyze
so what we did was we initially we
started out we did a thousand students a
week
as they came onto campus 2600 the second
week
four and a half thousand the third week
this is really a very rapid
rapid ramp up and since then we've
expanded to all students faculty staff
with at least weekly testing
and you know but
we expand this to the city of davis uh
we've got initiative called the healthy
davis together
which encompasses both the campus and
the city of davis
uh healthy davis together is really a
very holistic approach
we're just one component of that but uh
the rapid testing there are
kiosks uh around the city
as well as on campus that collect the
saliva samples
of asymptomatic individuals the
symptomatic individuals
they go to a different collection and go
through a different workflow
so we are in the genome center we're a
pop-up lab
we're an extension of the clear
certified student health lab
there's an md that's in charge of it
there are
doctors obviously recommending the tests
what you see here are the two
intellicubes
here that is very
important when you set up a high
throughput workflow to have redundancy
our actual workflow looks something like
this so
in the sampling kiosk the uh
the people will fit into a bar-coded
tube
and that is immediately in the
collection kiosk is put into a 96-well
rack
from that we can scan it we heat
inactivate
and one of the tricks to working with
saliva
is as you know saliva is very
viscous or at least some of it is and
this is problematic if you want wanted
to prepare
but uh ludz flanker who's the manager
the genie core had a
tech core had a brilliant idea
of using paper you know when you eat
papaya
your lips tingle that's because papain
is an aggressive protease
that's doing a number on your saliva and
just incubating
for propane can get rid of the viscosity
problem that really allowed us to work
with saliva
so we're analyzing raw saliva there's no
rna extraction
uh we can decap uh semi-automated
um semi-automated transfer 384 well
plates
those 384 well plates are placed on the
intellicube
and the intellicube does really all the
rest it sets up the reaction
and runs the reaction and then the
uh results from the reaction
are exported to the cloud where
a plug-in from using tech uses a knight
an approach that takes into account all
the curve
to call positives and negatives and if
you're interested in more of this
i encourage you to watch the video with
the link is at the top
they'll walk you through the process
so question of course is when you're
working
with high throughput raw saliva what's
your sensitivity
we're running uh the m1n2
fda approved test same prime as some
probes
we can get down to an lod of about 15
copies we're actually
the latest results that's 12 copies per
microliter of saliva
and this is comparable to some of the uh
euas for mp swaps so it isn't the most
sensitive test but it's certainly
um it's certainly sensitive enough
and with two intelli cubes we could do
in theory up to easily 12 000 samples
in a 12-hour day
right so in terms of throughput
rapid we've gone
we've now recorded over 400 000 tests
and we get the results back
the 33 10 can go back on the same day
and from this uh we've detected over
positive and because of the rapid
turnaround time
we can rapidly quarantine the
individuals
and follow up on their close contacts
now the workflow is high throughput
the sample collection really isn't uh
rate limiting the accessioning
is the rate limiting step even though we
have a very very simple workflow
this is what limits us at the moment we
regularly do four to five thousand
samples
we could ramp up to eight thousand a day
i think fairly comfortably
the two machines are not rate limiting
in many workflows it's the analysis of
the qpcr step that becomes rate limiting
but because we have this state system
this is not rate limiting to us the
north of data analysis
now because of this it's not being rate
limiting that gives us
spare capacity to look for
variance of concern and to use the same
workflow
but now uh using different primer sets
to look for variants but before i move
on to that
i want to acknowledge this has been a
massive team effort
a lot of people across campus got
mobilized
have a big team in the collection kiosks
we have uh three team uh three teams in
the testing lab
uh two production teams and one
development team
data management's really important
many people in administration never
underestimate the
the importance of having a an
enthusiastic and efficient
administration has been extremely
helpful
and then all this has been developed in
collaboration with lgc
that makes the intelli cubes with
perspectives
from cortava though they were very
useful in the initial stages
as we set up the high throughput
workflow so moving on to detecting
variants there is a real need
for surveillance of consequential
variants
now very viral evolution is inevitable
mutations are happening all the time
and most of these mutations are going to
be inconsequential
but a few of them are in fact going to
have a consequence
they'll increase the fitness of the
virus and because of that
they'll be selected for an increase
increasing frequency
and the problem is there is an
effectively
infinite population size from the
newly generated mutations the current
selection
is for increased transmissibility and
that's what we've seen
you get the b117s the b1 3.1
t1 etc from that originally were
identified in the uk
africa and in brazil respectively
so as you get a roll out of vaccines
that puts a very steep selection
pressure that will render the vaccines
less effective
so increased virulence and
vaccine escapes are probably inevitable
some predict that vaccines will not even
last 12 months
what we need to do is to try and
minimize what we call a boom and bust
cycle
i'll have a slide on that next slide i
think the scary thing is
what we're currently doing is only
practice for when vaccine and variants
appear
that are not controlled so
if anyone has any doubts about whether
evolution can occur
they just need to have a look at what's
happening with
sars kirby too
so what i mean by the boom and bust
cycle i say i come from a plant disease
background
with plants and plant diseases there are
recurring plant disease pandemics and
actually wheat rust that dem devastated
wheat production in the us from the 50s
you get this term where
you screen germplasm for uh resistance
you identify as sources of resistance
you breathe it
release it it increases in acreage
steeps electron pressure
pathogen changes your bacterial set will
cultivar
and you go around around this cycle boom
and bust cycle
and this is what's likely to happen with
vaccines we'll have
highly vaccine highly effective vaccines
deployed
and that puts the steep selection
pressure on the pathogen
the virus changes will occur that render
it ineffective
we'll need to develop more vaccines what
we need to do is to try and slow down
this cycle
we need to maximize the evolutionary
hurdle
for the pathogen and the key to that
is monitoring the pathogen
so you know psalms kobe 2
will continually evolve so it's actually
evolving relatively slowly to some other
things like the flu virus
you know the three new strains of
current concern b117
b1351 and bp1
they may be more contagious uh this
particular mutation known as uh
n501y and another one the e484
which is in the binding site what's
shown here is
a model of the uh
well the structure of the
um of the s-protein
which is binding the interface to the
receptor and you see these mutations
from the receptor binding
interface it was initially identified
actually because one of the primers
for a commonly used test for kovid
was actually spanning a deletion
uh for the one of mutations that
is present in the v117 string
our test uh is a very common test for
the m1 and n2
that hasn't yet been affected by
mutations in the virus
but uh we're certainly looking out for
that
so what we now do is
uh use our technology with no mutations
to monitor for variants of concern we're
also monitoring wastewater that's a
different project
and waste water is turning out to be
very very informative
as to whether you've got the virus there
you know why we're interested in this
clearly some of the viruses
some of the variants are apparently
less controlled by the vaccines
already
the data is still coming in as to which
vaccines are more or less affected
by these new variants coming in and this
is really beyond the scope of this
character
talk to cover all of that but suffice it
to say it's extremely important to
monitor for variance
the question is how do we do that i
think
so the two things on the table of
whether we genotype
or whether we sequence sequencing
is obviously the the gold standard you
can sequence the whole virus
you can look at it you can put look at
the phylogeny
but there's a cost you really can't the
one of the
biggest things about sequencing is the
throughput is so much lower
the cost is higher uh you have to
extract rna
it's relatively uh the complexity is
higher
the turnaround is certainly much slower
i said the resolution is much better and
of course if your only genotyping for
known snips
you won't get the nervous discovery
so i think we need to concern why
are we doing what the two technologies
are complementary
if you do snip genotyping so you're just
looking at positions in the genome
that you know could be consequential you
can then monitor
in high throughput for variance of
concern
you won't detect new consequential
variants and that's why we certainly
need to be sequencing
as many isolates as possible and getting
a good random sample
the genotyping the message here i think
is genotyping is complementary
sequencing
so the divergence type we do and again
i'd say we're developing these slip
acids in collaboration with
lgbt the the intelli cube and the
in the next equipment that i showed you
in my third slide
they were actually developed to monitor
for snips
they were designed and therefore it's
the ideal technology to deploy
for high throughput snip analysis the
way it works
is you have a forward and reverse primer
and this is just the same assay has been
used
for detecting the virus in the first
place except in this case
you have not only a probe a match probe
but you have a mismatched probe
and the way that these assays work is
you have a short
rna sequence that is
targets over the under the
polymorphic position and these sequences
uh these probes are not fluorescent
because they have a quencher that
sciences quenches the fluorescent signal
now if you have different fluorochromes
linked to different match and mismatched
probes
they will compete for each other
depending on the sequence
and you will get a strong signal when
there's a
match and a weak signal when there's a
mismatch
so we have uh up to 14 assays currently
working
for those familiar in the field will be
very familiar
they're the usual suspects of sites that
we're targeting
and you can see the variance of concern
here
and a variant of interest and you get a
different pattern
of presence or absence of the variant
site which will allow us
to rapidly distinguish between
the different strains
the type of readout here's a two pcr
traced off the intellicube
you can see that here's all the
wild-type ones going on in blue
off to the left and actually
we're running samples here these are
either raw saliva samples
or in some cases they are actually from
symptomatic individuals
where we've taken the left over from the
panther run
so this is the nasal swab in vtm
and you see we get a really nice signal
there too
and then you've got the variance running
along the bottom
so you can see very clear distinction
between the fluorochromes coming up
the fluorescent signal coming off from
the variant
as of from the wild type
so this is uh the deletion this
characteristic of
b117 uh
here's the uh n501y
you can see we've got uh again
several b117s here
up the wires type clear distinction
then uh e4 84k
this is not present in the b117 but it
is present
in p1 and the bu1351
and here we've got clear distinction
from the variant strain
from the wild type
so here's some examples of
different snap assays what we're showing
here
is the uh is the
endpoint analysis just
a little bit easier to see right uh
eight genotyping assays but you can see
we get really good clustering
of the of the variance from
the wild type which allows us to call
uh fingerprint each sample
uh the the ct value
the cutoff is about a ct value of 30
which is about the same thresholds for
sequencing below 30 we get strong signal
30 to 32 we're getting uh more and more
knocker
more and more dropouts and above 32 33
we really don't get any reliable signal
so what we're currently doing at davis
we can take a variety of inputs rule
saliva sold samples or extracted rna
we're screening all our positives
so all the positives that come through
from the asymptomatic screening
and then we're also picking up
symptomatic individuals as well
with genotype and 14 loci um
we have rapid turnaround we can uh have
informative data
with a few samples of collection
you know and all the non-wild type
samples
the variance of concern variants of
interest or things that
just don't conform to the haplotype that
we'd expect
we sequence validate them the illumina
sequencing
takes another week or so and then we
report the results to the
york county health officer
so an example of this we we
had a sample and uh it was collected
26th of march two days later we
genotyped it
and the genotype as you can see here
with variancy
e484k k4
417n and the n501y
now that is characteristic
of the uh b1351 you can see
it matches this very nicely as as it did
for the other load side
turn that off for sequencing and about a
week later
we had it sequence validated so
doing 100 of our positives get genotyped
and it allows us to pick up the pick up
the frequency
of each of the variants
so summarizing
the sniff assays of variants the
advantages are
they're high throughput they're rapid
they're inexpensive
and they're multiple types of snip
assays available
we're not the only show in town uh
several
um different groups are rolling out snip
athletes you can anything that's
basically pc-horrible
you can use as a template in many cases
you
can use the residuals from whatever test
you're running in the whatever primary
test you're using
there is no need for rna extraction uh
you have a very flexible adaptable panel
of informative snips
as the sequencing discovers more steps
uh variants of concern and the critical
snips that are characteristic of that
variant
it takes about hopefully a three to four
week turnaround time
from the discovery of that to deploying
it uh
commercially it can be run on any qptr
machine
in fact it's very low tech it could be
just endpoint assays
anyone with a pcr machine and a
fluorescent plate reader
could be generating this data now the
thing to stress
it's very definitely complementary to
sequencing
we can monitor very large numbers of
samples
the information generated in real time
to allow public health interventions
but it doesn't replace the need for
sequencing
it relies stand on the shoulders of
sequencing
to identify new steps of interest
but it does allow triaging and samples
to be sequenced
and reducing redundant uh sequencing uh
if you think about it the
the normal information content of
sequencing
is reduced asymptotics more and more
sequences
of more samples of sequence
also it doesn't compete with the supply
chain sequencing
now that i think the the technical
challenges
are minimal to doing this what is much
bigger are the regulatory challenges
this is not an fda authorized test and
it's it's ambiguous to what the point is
still being worked out
as to what extent we can report the
genotyping results
or we have to wait for sequence
validation before reporting them
and i think um this is very important
that
the the regulatory environment has to
change
so we can fully exploit the potential of
this of this technology
the importance of testing this events
after vaccination
you know the the vaccines they're being
rolled out
in impressive speed but the efficacy
data relies
on the prevention of disease
how many people came symptomatic nucleic
acid tests were not
part of that efficacy calculation
and we know though 40 percent of
infections are asymptomatic
uh there's little data though it's
beginning to come
on how frequently vaccinated individuals
become
become infected and are infectious to
others
so it's critically important to monitor
the variants of child's cov2
that reduce the protection of the
vaccines as we've already mentioned
b1351
identified in south africa has many
changes in spike protein
and it's been reported that it is uh the
vaccines are not so effective against it
and as i've said earlier the evolution
of
variants that compromise the effects of
vaccines is probably
probably inevitable therefore
it's very important to continue testing
after vaccination
uh something that we've experienced is
as the the frequency of backstage
individuals go up
people say i'm vaccinated i don't need
to get tested
i think that's heading for a train wreck
we really need to make sure that
vaccinated individuals do continue to
get tested
so this requires monitoring and
genotyping of results in the context of
vaccination records and as soon as we
see a vaccine escape of course
that gets plugged into the sequencing
pipeline
so you're one of the future prospects
genotyping is rapid inexpensive
and you can do a large uh proportion of
positives
the technology exists where you could
actually genotype the majority of
positives detected
in the u.s it's just a matter of the
will to deploy the technology to do this
what's also very important is that there
should be
certain events on the global scale and
in many countries around the world
sequencing
is just not feasible but these
relatively low tech tests
could be performed and then the the
alarm could be raised
when you get variants blowing up in
certain areas obviously we still need to
sequence from these areas
but uh intense sequencing for much of
the world
is is just not feasible again
stressing it's complementary to
sequencing uh
what we need is continual development
and deployment of new genotyping assays
with a three to four week development
cycle we
need regulatory acceptance for public
health actions
and ultimately i think we should be
getting work towards getting fda
approval
for geotyping by clear labs for patient
interventions
so when uh strains
that clearly are overcoming vaccine
vaccines
um you know that then is actionable
at the patient level and right now
the sequencing is way too slow so we
need to
work out a way of rapid genotyping
to say which variant a patient has and
then drive the intervention
so that's it i'd like to wrap up and and
then the credits here
you know this has been a lot of work
from the testing sequencing
to work out the assets and particularly
i'd like to credit the
lgc design team uh lindy mclennan
and tanya nolan in particular that have
helped us
they give us the the pro primes and
probe sets we test them
out on on experimental and clinical
samples
it's been a tremendous interaction
and with that i will wrap up thank you
for your attention